famous lesson about a margin of safety
you don't drive a truck that weighs
ninety nine hundred pounds across a
bridge that says limit ten thousand
pounds because you can't be that sure
about it if you see something like that
you go down a little further down the
road and you find one that says limit
twenty thousand pounds and that's the
way across the nature of capitalism is
that people want to come in and take
your castles perfectly understand if I'm
solving television sets or something
there's going to be ten other people who
are gonna try and sell a better
television set if I have a restaurant
here in Omaha people are gonna try and
copy my menu and get more parking and
take my chef and so on so capitalism is
all about somebody coming and trying to
take the castle now what you need is you
need a castle that has some durable
competitive advantage some castle that
has a moat around one of the best moats
in many respects is to be a low-cost
producer but sometimes the motors just
having more talent I mean if you're the
heavyweight champion in the world you
keep knocking out people you've got a
competitive advantage as long as you can
keep doing it and it's very profitable
if you're the one that happens to be
able to do it you just watch two amazing
clips and Warren Buffett take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]